it's a pool a Capcom exclusive you know
that's somebody ASAP someone who I feel
like is like definitely taking a lot
from you guys but he's also giving
credit you know yeah and that's that
that matters down now now and as of
lately you know what I mean the game
remix brought a lot of light back to the
situation and things like that man but I
think you know when when you when you
teaching somebody anything if you got
kids you know I mean and you show them
you showing them how to ride a bike and
all that and you they finally fall and
fall and fall and they finally get it
and do it on their own and you're
probably you know I mean because for one
that's a creation of you and yeah you
know I'm saying so know back in the days
we come from the era of don't bite my
don't bite my music right ready no would
be fighters
I remember y'all beat that with crews
conflict a little bit yeah I mean a lot
of people said we stone a style because
we was on we was on to something so
innovative you know what I mean that a
lot of people try to take what take what
what in there I remember yeah I remember
it was always like a tosser it was like
people would always say it was like
twister music conflict in y'all and you
know people always you know who started
this this this this type of you know
even out of LA they had the Freestyle
fellowship and even those guys still be
thinking you know like like we somehow
listen to some music and Connor came and
and bit their style man you know and all
of us I don't think crucial conflict did
that or do or die or twister I just
think it was an energy around what we
were doing and the energy is gonna catch
on it isn't just with us and Cleveland
the energy is just out further I mean
just like that song that we heard before
the you and I were talking about the new
Eminem song where the other guy mr.
Levine is doing that movie when he's
singing about the movie where area and
electric long lazy I just did a course
line that was so similar to a source my
life energy you know what I'm saying so
sometimes that does happen don't you
brave it out into the universe you got
capitalize on the man because you know
everybody knows with this world it's all
about duplication it's all in the laws
of branding you know what I mean that's
all all the major record labels dude a
something that get high rock and roll
got hiding in that it became a whole
Torah and things like that man so we we
basically Bone Thugs men are we happy to
be here we happy to to be or blessed to
be chosen man to be at the forefront of
something that's gonna be with music for
forever you know I'm saying like to put
more words and more syllables and you
know more adjectives and stuff in your
rhymes and things like that man is like
back back when we when we first started
the game the rap game was kind of slow
you know I mean it wasn't that many
words put into it so it was like like
right now you can compare bone as to
Xbox 360 right compared to Atari right
right so like we just stepped a game of
111 not and that was a lot of people
who's chopped like that you know who
ripped like that you know we we just
want to work with a lot more these
artists you know what I'm saying to
really just be involved in and you know
when you a rapper man you add everybody
like the state they claim and show what
they can do Minister it's a confidence
sport you know me for sure
long thugs want to be involved so you
know I mean so whoever out there doing
it and want to do something with with it
with the originators you know I mean we
down for that man we back we're doing
our thing we five live we rocking out
tonight folks show on vine and get it
definitely definitely going we gonna
rock the house you know what I mean so
we bout to have fun that we always get
mad love out here there's like a second
home no for real this is I think that
this might man I'm telling you man y'all
getting so much love out here like it's
crazy man yeah man we out here man we
got our peoples out here like flesh was
talking about his group the duct tape
gang is out here you know we got
position out here with the live
entertainment
a big slow now here in a candy righto
with with the motive family harmony
house entertainment so I am you guys are
all from Cleveland and I feel like like
there's there's finally you know a few
guys coming out of Cleveland of course
Cuddy's been doing this thing on big
chair and then MGK who's really kind of
hot right now
um I know he every time I've talked to
MGK you know he's given a lot of love to
y'all my dog yeah how do you guys feel
about like like that young kid MGK
coming out of coming out of the city I
mean I love him okay man every time I
love the city you know what I'm saying
that he come to and and rocking in I go
out and support him with the Cleveland
love I jumped on his Cleveland remix you
know what I mean so it's all down
countless so but you know it's good to
see the hometown finally you know we try
to open the doors as much as we can we
help as many people as we possibly could
and you know it's good to see everybody
doing it on they own and taking the
initiative that we did you know meaning
and we here to work in hopefully one day
we don't have a big Cleveland
collaboration yeah don't blow it
craziest off to me and Wes you know hey
crazy who are some artists man um that
like you know your bumper right now
whether some new cancer yeah man just
like didn't say you know I listen to a
lot of dogs I'm feeling the Kendrick
Lamar you know like stuff like that you
don't saying that man I listen to music
here you know saying if there's good
music I listen to it you know I don't
really get caught up in like everything
that's out there you know the summer
video straight girl
if it's big men I listen to it where
there's always cool weather is new have
you guys you guys had a chance to
chopper a sample of course oh yeah yeah
I chopped it over you know he he a real
cool dude on earth you know saying like
a real he know he know very well about
boning the things we did more similar
you listen to his music you know it's
probably definitely runs in this it
definitely wasn't his family I actually
got to speak with his mother on the
following really she's a big bone things
that's crazy
ya know her his mom is like a straight
hip hop and she named him after I came
in on that oh you're like heat man like
they know you know myself
it ain't none but love my that's what's
up man
well you know me um I do my Justin
Bieber thank y'all don't like Justin
people I be riding with the Biebs I got
everyone his records man I swear T I'm a
beep fan man especially you know and
shots out to a Justin Bieber out there
I have okie be be blowing them trees to
me hey yo tonight it's going down it's
gonna be crazy man all five members on
stage wishbone maybe I don't know this
but I'm still waiting on this although
out that's what's up man flesh is good
to see you man and good spirits hey
always oh you coming out man like how
was how I mean be it being away so long
in there I'm watching these guys do all
these crazy hit records while you were
locked up man like is how hard was it
til I kind of get back and and pick up
that same vibe before you left you know
I've never miss do what I had to do
clean myself up you know what I said but
they were too hard had a hard time with
me if they wouldn't have been able to
you don't keep the ball rolling doing
the thing keeping a brand alive and
anything I was gonna have to put it off
put each one each one of them in a
headlock something to you feel me but it
was a it was honor and you know on the
blessed for me to be able to come home
and still have a career and keep the
ball up where I left off you feel me
that's that's basically what that was
for me there it is pretty much you know
vibes you know you know
kind of creative energy that we have for
me I'm winning then you know you know
worked on thousands of songs and
thousands of tracks and the abyss did
that study got a couple of degrees up
under my belt so forth of song and
business and stuff so I didn't it wasn't
time wasted you feel like y'all gotta
kind of like you know music sounds
certain way you know now I feel like you
guys have nothing never really kind of
compromised the bone sound with y'all
y'all feel like any pressure will never
feel pressured like oh we got to sound
like this because they doing that no no
no right we've been innovative and
creative enough they're always going to
invent something we come with these
funky vibes these funky grooves lyrics
whatever you want to call it and always
be the ones that say okay it's been you
know the outside of music as always a
motivational with the spirit with it
occur with a seed of motivational
inspirational element in it so with that
we like can do anything and like that's
that that when we omit that type of
energy and we're in the lab working that
type of magic that's what it's all about
and I'll pressure up but unflustered
always do nothing but keep keep it funky
all the time that's bone and what I and
what I wanted to add man like here we
are working then on something you know
what I mean and we actually working on
something totally brand new you know I
mean it's a it's capitalizing on our
style not so much as creating a new
style but more more team participation
man you know what I'm saying it's called
the universe there's the style that we
spit you right now okay
it's unite with the first you know what
I'm saying
so we unifying on these verses more than
just doing 16 things like right right
right right right I'm saying so like
with this new thing is much much harder
as much much tedious and I doubt if you
see any other glue backwards try because
it's a lot more it's a lot of work
behind it it's a lot of work ethic so
it's really taking us a minute to do it
because it's actually believe that that
intricate like laser was saying and just
to reiterate off something that you had
would asked about I think with music and
with bone thugs-n-harmony we really
we've always listened to like the
old-school songs like the ones that
sound good to your heart and when we
learned how to put words together as far
as poetry and understanding what makes
people think and we added that mesh in I
think it's what gives us that
down-to-earth vibe because it is no ways
about just a rap song we actually like
to sit down or listen to the old 70s and
the old j's and things of that nature so
it all adds to our spirit and it comes
across in the music you know the
harmonizing and crazy man and I think
crazy one of the most underrated like
just singers like you know this new guy
but it's like just the hooks and the
song right man yes bananas man so I
appreciate y'all tonight Marquis Theatre
lots of tickets available goes yeah
that's gonna be in store achill night in
Phoenix without chicken out of you in
Phoenix you will come on now all five
live's
first time all father's been on stage of
Phoenix and decking on almost 10 K so
y'all gotta come out be a part of
history
go get your tickets go borrow $10 from
the art see some grandpa that owed you
that money or whatever go get go get
your tickets now celebrate everybody
let's rock out sell out the show and
let's get in there
yes indeed that's exactly what we talked
about we happy to be here you guys and
oh we can't wait to see you this evening
though oh there it is cool